so I have a friend um
she's an actress she's in her 60s she's
super bright badass emotionally
intelligent and a couple of days before
Christmas she was at the post office it
was really crowded as it is around the
holidays and she was filling out some
forms and she was really focused and out
of nowhere someone moved her out of the
way just physically put their hands on
her and moved her out of the way he
apparently needed something that she was
blocking so he moved her maybe he had
said something to her maybe he didn't
she didn't hear it either way she was
focused she was filling out the form and
the next thing you know there were hands
on her and she was being moved out of
the way he then got what he was reaching
for whatever she was blocking and went
on his merry way
she said that she was shocked at first
yeah and then a fury rose up in her that
she could not explain not annoyance not
frustration but fury was the word that
she used and she went on to say I mean I
I wanted to get physical i-i-i-i I don't
know I was furious and I don't know why
I mean he didn't hit me he didn't hurt
me he didn't violate me he moved me and
I wanted to hurt him or at the very
least run after him and yell in his face
so later I was left pondering this fury
and looking for an explanation as to why
even in her telling of it I felt fury
too and why this was a word and a
feeling that I was hearing a lot about
lately I feel like this is the point in
the room where all the men are getting a
little bit uncomfortable it's okay
stay with me this fury is something that
I have been chomping
since the last u.s. presidential
election and it seems that many women
have this fury was not my friends alone
her fury was ignited by lifetimes of men
helping themselves to women's bodies
without consent there's a culture of men
helping themselves to women and in this
case in a seemingly innocuous way where
a woman's body is like a salt shaker you
get out of the way so I can get the
fries to the most egregious violent and
horrific situations I imagine that some
of you are wondering what the connection
is between the innocuous and the
horrific to things that seem to be on
opposite ends of the spectrum well the
common thread is the spectrum the
innocuous makes space for the horrific
and women have to live with the effects
of both and everything in between
fellas can you imagine if you're just on
your phone and someone walks up to you
and just takes it out of your hand
they're like I'm gonna dude I don't know
why you're getting so upset I want to
make a phone call I'm gonna give it back
to you as soon as I'm done whatever and
then imagine if someone takes that cell
phone out of your hands I don't know
once a day twice a day random times and
the explanation is yeah well I mean you
got a fancy case or you shouldn't have
taken it out of your pocket or yep yeah
that's just the way it is but somehow no
one ever talks about the person who took
the cell phone overly simplified I get
it but you see where I'm going
men are so used to helping themselves
that it's like it can't help themselves
and not because men are fundamentally
less moral but because this is a very
big blind spot for most men when someone
helps themselves to a woman it not only
triggers discomfort and distress but the
unspoken experiences of our mothers
lives sisters lives and generations of
women before us
that's lifetime's of women dealing with
men who assume they know better for us
than we know for ourselves being the
property of husbands landowners and
having old white men tell us the fate of
our ladyparts
lifetimes of having our bodies used for
love and objects of desire instead of
bodies that we get to wield and use as
we choose lifetimes of knowing that
whether we play by their rules or not we
still have to tolerate harassment
assault and even worse lifetimes of our
bodies being used as property that can
be hit and hurt manipulated and moved
and like objects that are not deserving
of respect lifetimes of not being able
to express the anger of our bodies it's
no wonder we feel this fury and if you
add in the history of race which is a
whole other talk it gets exponentially
more complicated when women get
manhandled we start to rationalize try
to figure out the ways that it was it
was probably our fault you know what he
probably said something and I didn't
hear him oh my god I'm just overreacting
totally overreacting no no
no no no no no no women have been
trained to think that we are
overreacting or that we're being too
sensitive or unreasonable we try to make
sense of nonsense and we swallow the
furious feelings we try to put them into
some some hidden place in our minds but
they don't go away that fury sits deep
inside as we practice our smiles yes of
course and try to be pleasant I know yes
yes of course because apparently women
aren't supposed to get angry that fury
that my friend felt holds centuries of
never being able to directly address or
express our indignation our frustration
and our rage when someone thinks they
can help themselves to our bodies it not
only ignites the current fury but it
lights up the past what seems like a
benign moment at the post office
is actually an anger grenade
well kaboom
today the global collection of women's
experiences can no longer be ignored
time's up I'm thinking that we're
overreacting or this is just the way it
is
time's up on women being held
responsible for men's bad behavior it is
men's responsibility to change men's bad
behavior
our culture is shifting and it's time so
my fellow women and our gentle men as we
are here together within this particular
window of this large-scale movement
towards women's equality and as we
envision a future that does not yet
exist we both have different invitations
men I call you in as allies as we work
together towards change
may you be accountable and self
reflective compassionate and open may
you ask how you can support a woman and
be of service to change and may you get
help if you need it
and women I encourage you to acknowledge
your fury give it language share it in
safe places of identification and in
safe ways your fury is not something to
be afraid of
it holds lifetime's of wisdom let it
breathe and listen thank you
[Applause]